yeah and what do you think do you think
that you're going to take it for the
rest of your life obviously my opinions
don't weigh anything anymore so that's
when you say stuff like that is your
little way of going a little digging a
little dagger on my side I hope it's a
downer I hope that you don't take it
personally because you know I have a man
I'm a man I'm going to say something
okay I have a lot of flaws I have good
qualities too hmm
I'm aware of my good qualities I have a
lot of bad qualities and I have
behavioral routines that I do they have
just been routine you know and it's hard
to break and I admit to you that it is
something that I foresee a problem but
it's difficult to break same with
destiny it's so difficult for me you
just have a very very addictive person I
do and it's it's something I've always
had like he can't just eat sunflower
seeds like a normal person do you go
through a whole bag and he spits it
every single corner of the house there's
just seeds everywhere you see my car
right now and so now the same thing it's
like him you know those I sees those
frozen little delights if you can't just
have one look at her freezer it's just a
hundred I sees just back from body can I
defend myself what the eye sees alone if
I tell you nice it's every summer okay
if you go to CVS or rite-aid there's one
company that makes this stuff called
Italian ice right there called Wycliffe
or something right with the singer I
don't know and is that the one that it's
every summer yeah net bags no not in the
net bags these are not as I see as much
as they almost have a creamy consistency
to them yeah they're very the quality of
the ice is very very good it's like you
know when you go to Korean food and you
have popping sue yeah there's the shitty
ice and then there's they're really good
fluffy ice well this Italian ice is like
a fluffy ice
pretty good stuff and they only come out
in the summer if you go to the winter
I've asked where's the white cliff
they're gonna it's only a summer thing
so every summer I'll get a puppy when we
first the last summer whatever I used to
get like you 9:19 boxes Oh bolt used by
bone my problem isn't that he eats them
it's that he doesn't know where the
trashcan is so there's sticky sticky
plastic wrappers on the side of the bed
in the bed everywhere I walk it's icy
wrappers and sunflower seeds yeah this
is the [ __ ] recipe of for animals
yeah I have a lot of problems but
addictions but you know what our life is
good mm-hmm let's circle with the
positives okay okay the the massage
thing with my dick thing I only did it
that one time when you did work at home
I have been using it on myself since why
do you think it's out okay good for you
yeah and I got a yeast infection after
oh that's your bad no that's your bad
whatever the [ __ ] you I don't want you
oh you didn't worry